the black flame ash of war weapon art is
one of the coolest weapon arts i have
seen in this entire game the location to
get it in is in windmill heights as far
north on the map as you can possibly go
once you get to the base of this town
you're going to find a grey spot to rest
and you will see a windmill town full of
women who are just dancing and having a
good time it is disturbing it is weird
they're not hostile at all they are just
dancing laughing having a good time and
it's one of the creepiest things i've
seen in this game so far you cannot tell
me that eldon ring is not in the horror
category at this point there's so many
horrifying things in this game and
really creepy stuff as well kind of like
this once you make your way up the hill
of this town you will find a boss fight
called the godskin apostle to get the
black flame tornado weapon art you need
to defeat this boss you also get his
weapon which is called the godskin
peeler it has some really cool normal
base attacks as well and decent damage
and that is how you get the black flame
tornado ashes of war weapon art it is so
incredible i'm gonna show you guys the
end of the boss fight the boss fight
isn't too hard especially since you get
to use torrent against this boss you
just kind of weave in and out hitting
him with a heavy attack like i did and
he gets down pretty quick but i'm gonna
show you guys the end of the boss fight
and my reaction to seeing the weapon art
for the first time i hope you guys
enjoyed the video make sure to like and
subscribe and come check out our twitch
channel we're streaming this game hours
and hours and hours every single day and
learning new things every day as well
i'd love to have you there thanks for
watching the video guys and have a great
day
[ __ ] me
i ain't about any of that right there
none of that
[Music]
i [ __ ] up
i pressed too hard on the stick
one more voice
i miss
and [ __ ]
up let's go
man
godskin peller
peeler
black flame
whoa
two-handed
black flame tornado
yeah
what
takes a lot of fp to do that though
really cool weapon yeah
really cool weapon